war against mamadaro to secure the match
win that means he finishes off with
three points it's a loss for Mom Daryl
but
a big thank you to both these players
for their fantastic entertainment
throughout the season and Wesley so he
won suddenly the first Blitz game
against Anish giri something happened
that probably some time travel it looks
like Gary yeah under some time pressure
just let things slide it wasn't a
knockout blow it wasn't just a one move
blunder but step by step Wesley pushed
him back pushed him back pushed his
pawns forward and won a nice end game so
yeah Wesley just in great form these
last few days and Gary unfortunately for
him just out of shape right now
definitely there will be a Blitz game
too starting in a very few minutes in
each with the white pieces has to win it
to take it to Armageddon and then game
four is going on with Prague and there
you guys see they are tied before game
four bars still very much over to
Parkside he could decide this final
match of the season
and